I had horrible positive breast cancer seven years ago, my body tolerated to moxin for four
years besides dim, what would be the next best supplement to prevent metastatic disease?
Well, your natural aromatase inhibitors are going to be dim, so for a fame, and you can
go to our website, countersclinic.com, and just search natural aromatase or search, search
aromatase. And that's, I have a whole list of it, an article on natural aromatase inhibitors
and things that I would suggest, so I'll let you do that because we're going to be
interdated with questions. But to moxin, if it is an aromatase, it hemics blocking all
estrogens, you tolerated it well, and it's helped a lot. But when you get to the point, I know
they want people to take it for 10 years, sometimes they'll tell people they're going to take
it's a rest of your life, and it can be intolerable. It does block all your estrogens, not just
your bad estrogens, so looking for a natural aromatase inhibitor might be a wise choice. Also,
running a Dutch test would be, what we talked about earlier in the show would be a wise choice,
too, because that's going to give you a picture where your horrible Zarat and how much you really need
to hit, how hard you need to hit, trying to do natural aromatase inhibitors.